hello everybody my name is Mark bar and
this is Bob and Wade what is it well
good wine well I don't know what is he
loving it I think he's just laughing cuz
we're both just like my two bodyguards
here are back from Cincinnati except for
you that's not where you're from one of
those is back from Cincinnati Olli yes I
said Raleigh yeah that's the one
no van checkers they call it chunk of
said no van it's checkers in the cell no
no that I'm saying like when you
pronounce Nevada people get mad yeah we
gotta say rally you pronounce it Nevada
you know rally sure anyway hello welcome
to the Monday vlog it's late but then
again I said it was gonna be late
because I was picking up these goofs at
the airport they just flew in for so
they just flew in from wherever they
came from Raleigh Raleigh and Cincinnati
to do videos with us here for a full
week not a full week's like four days
yes most of a week it's most of a week
its mode the most productive cycle of
the week we've got a whole list of stuff
that we're gonna be doing all week long
and that includes us going out and
finding you guys through various parts
of Los Angeles so we're gonna be in
various places all Wednesday long we're
gonna be going to a whole bunch of
different places we're gonna try to get
a rally and no that's that's single Asst
oh it's reflecting Nevada gotta let the
joke go away
exactly we're actually talking about
different locations now you know an
improv it's called callback the apples
to be extra funny when you call back
yeah the longer you let it wait though
the funnier the callback is okay I want
to do say we're Holly again yeah just
last word cuz definitely Raleigh was the
funniest thing we've said in the past
few
there's a lot of fluids being exchanged
here and I don't much appreciate it
decided I'll just try I don't know what
you guys are doing alright so anyway
we're off topic here thank you guys so
much for being patient on this vlog we
have had so many things in planning for
this week and we're ready to get going
on videos videos are going to be regular
after this one but in when it comes to
next week when we finally have all the
stuff recorded and we're getting all
that everything done it's going to be
super fun with lots of new types of
videos not really
same old we're nothing original ah
Rowley I'm bill shut I see you waited
shut up
so now we're gonna continue this vlog I
have nothing else to say
Raleigh Raleigh what do you mean what
are you doing Tyler's behind the camera
stretch it out to Phil you gotta feel
ten minutes we gotta do this you
what is everyone always telling me oh
don't spoil the surprise and you can't
even save time he's yesterday I got
lectured for Spencer because everyone
said I'm spoiling the surprise I'm
saying this isn't peace
all right Bob like how you yelled that
way and there's more people to yell at
over there
here it's all nice got Bob Catherine and
Ethan I even is telling more people over
there to yell that no but he doesn't
want yell at the no say no we're off
topic again hi my name is markiplier and
we're here to tell you about this
fun-filled week that I'm about to spoil
for all of you you aren't gonna see this
till next week oops
Ida uh just tomorrow tonight we're gonna
do Let's Plays tomorrow we're gonna do
challenges Wednesday we're gonna do
Fanny track fans stop I said
wait I said that I said Wednesday we're
all gonna be doing the fan stuff I
already said this we know exactly what
we're gonna be doing and when we're
gonna be doing it so be on the lookout
we're gonna tell you guys about it we're
already on Wednesday be on the lookout
we're gonna be there this is very
threatening maybe we should the
president you're gonna pay you're gonna
be their president we're gonna be there
we're gonna meet you guys Shatner
that was like an Obama bomb oh we're
gonna be there that's not what I did at
all
that's a we're gonna be there pleasure
dear anything I gonna be they're gonna
be living well this is all irrelevant to
exactly the point that I'm trying to
make is that I'm literally just filling
time I have nothing else of substance to
say so thank you everybody so much for
watching it's gonna be a fun week we get
the whole gang here we got a whole week
full of stuff to do it's gonna be super
exciting and I can't wait to show you
guys I'm super like incredibly thankful
that my friends are out here again just
to be serious like I really do miss you
guys on a day-to-day basis and then you
don't play games enough no wait till
tonight I didn't miss you guys dearly
every second that you're not so anyway I
just wanted to say that you guys are
awesome I forgive you for spitting on me
now you're welcome I mean there's gonna
be a lot more spit coming to you so Bob
would you like to say anything before we
go
oh god pulley on the spa why don't you
yes all the exact same things that Mark
had said but more eloquently said that's
probably promised Rolly it does I will
say being in LA is pretty exciting cuz
we were all here before for once
previously yeah that was a long time ago
no three of us yeah three of us have
been here not you you know camera if
you're not on camera uh you're not even
a person to me right now exactly those
guys they're cool oh yeah these guys
just Tyler's not in person
anyway was I say uh you were being
grateful and thankful for friendship oh
yeah oh yeah I look at that point of
what I'm saying time but our
Italian it is incredible that the three
of us together in LA hasn't happened in
years literally years yeah that's
depressing
over two years now you the only time
I've come out here was like right after
you've had first moved out yeah so two
almost three years ago oh yeah almost
three years so at least two years ago
but whatever remark appliers magic touch
came out then yeah yeah oh my god that
was it holy
I can't believe everyone didn't just
start grabbing me when I walked in the
house today well I mean you know who you
is like the car could I whatever anyway
so it's gonna be an awesome time we've
got all of us here just to have fun and
have fun with you guys and to make fun
videos for you all to enjoy so look
forward to what's coming soon thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always we'll see you in the next video
bye bye
oh wait wait did you want to say do you
like to say something I'm good you're
gonna cut I can't toss Bob's eloquence
okay alright the eloquent Bob cannot be
tough I'm sorry oh
Oh